[Música]
2000 nuevos presos fueron trasladados a
la recién inaugurada mega cárcel de El
Salvador con este grupo ya son en total
4000 personas recluidas en estas
instalaciones en medio de las
preocupaciones de Defensores de Derechos
Humanos por posibles abusos
el ciclón yaku sigue causando estragos
en Perú las intensas lluvias han
provocado deslizamientos de tierra en
Lima donde el gobierno de la presidenta
Dina boluarte amplió el estado de
emergencia para atender la situación
protestas en Bolivia en la ciudad de
Potosí sus habitantes bloquearon vías
para presionar a las autoridades aprobar
un proyecto de ley que garantice que los
beneficios de la explotación de litio
sean reinvertidos en esa zona
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en El
Salvador el gobierno informó que envió a
otros dos mil presos a la mega cárcel de
alta seguridad recientemente inaugurada
por el presidente nayib bukele el
mandatario público un tweet en el que
informó que ya son 4000 los detenidos en
el llamado centro de confinamiento del
terrorismo previo a la publicación de
bukele no se había informado sobre el
traslado de los reos organizaciones
defensoras de derechos humanos han
expresado su preocupación por este
centro ante el riesgo existente de
posibles abusos
este día en un nuevo operativo
trasladamos al segundo grupo de 2000
pandilleros al centro de confinamiento
del terrorismo con esto ya son 4,000
pandilleros los que habitan la cárcel
más criticada del mundo
Estados Unidos y Rusia continúan
acusándose y lanzando advertencias sobre
la responsabilidad del incidente que
compromete un dron de bandera
estadounidense que fue presuntamente
interceptado por aviones militares rusos
en el espacio aéreo internacional y que
posteriormente se estrelló en aguas del
mar Negro
Moscú niega haber tenido contacto con la
aeronave y advirtió a Washington que se
mantenga alejado de su espacio aéreo el
ministro de relaciones exteriores de
Rusia sergei labrov asegura que Estados
Unidos ignora las restricciones del
espacio aéreo del mar Negro mientras el
Secretario de Defensa estadounidense
loud Austin afirmó que su país
continuará volando y operando donde lo
permita el derecho internacional
hablé por teléfono con mi homólogo ruso
el ministro shoygu
como dije repetidamente es importante
que las grandes potencias sean modelos
de transparencia y comunicación
Estados Unidos continuará volando y
operando donde lo permite el derecho
internacional y le corresponde a Rusia
operar sus aeronaves militares de manera
segura y profesional
ignoraron por completo el hecho de que
después del inicio de la operación
militar especial nuestro ejército ha
declarado ciertas áreas del mar Negro
cerca de la costa como áreas con acceso
limitado a cualquier vehículo aéreo y
esto diría es un descuido tan desafiante
que hace pensar que el lado
estadounidense busca constantemente
provocaciones para alimentar la
confrontación
vamos a Perú donde el paso del ciclón
yaku continuó causando devastación en
Lima el área metropolitana quedó
cubierta de lodo luego de que las
intensas lluvias provocaran
deslizamientos de tierra que afectaron
edificaciones carreteras la situación
llevó a la presidenta Dina boluarte a
ampliar el estado de emergencia para
esta zona previamente hablamos con Julio
gagó regidor de la municipalidad
Metropolitana de Lima quien nos hizo un
balance de lo que ha dejado el ciclón
tras su paso acá en Lima metropolitana
estamos tratando Este paso del ciclón
trabajando de la mano con el gobierno
central y el gobierno municipal el
gobierno municipal encabezado por Rafael
López aliada que es el alcalde de Lima y
en el caso de gobierno Central es la
presidenta Gina bolarte pero a través
del Ministerio de defensa porque estamos
trabajando juntamente con el ejército el
ejército hoy día está trabajando de la
mano justamente para tratar en lo
posible de evitar
de prevenir de que los problemas sean
mucho menores que los daños sean mucho
Menores en la diferentes zonas antes que
sucedan los daños estamos explicando
mucho a la población para que se retiren
del lugar que va a ser afectado unos
como tú bien sabes no quieren retirarse
porque viven en unas laderas en la
Ladera de los cerros donde tienen sus
propiedades otros están siendo evacuados
y estamos logrando de esa manera
minimizar hoy día los riesgos y los
desastres en cada lugar de Lima donde se
está presentando
vamos a Brasil el estado de Río Grande
donoche ha experimentado una serie de
ataques violentos en los últimos días y
en los que edificios públicos han sido
atacados y varios vehículos han sido
incendiados desarrollo de Janeiro
nuestra corresponsal Valeria sakone nos
explicó la situación
sería la reacción de
una serie de detenciones y también a la
prevención de armas y drogas en el
estado de Río Grande donoorchi en el
norte de Brasil han sido dos noches de
terror en Qué edificios públicos han
sido atacados con armas de fuego también
han sido incendiados autobuses hay al
menos dos heridos y la policía
investigación comerciante muerto podría
estar relacionado con esos ataques en
algunas ciudades como natal la capital
de ese estado o mostró se han tenido que
suspender servicios básicos como el
transporte público los ambulatorios las
escuelas finalmente el presidente del
país se lo hice en acero la Silva ha
enviado fuerzas especiales federales
Para apoyar a la policía local y además
la policía ha abatido al supuesto
cabecilla de esta facción que sería en
tesis el responsable de haber organizado
esta ola violenta de
pasamos a Colombia a una explosión en un
conjunto de seis minas de Carbón dejó 11
personas muertas mientras que las
autoridades continúan en la búsqueda de
10 mineros que quedaron atrapados los
hechos ocurrieron la noche del martes en
el municipio de sus atausa en el centro
del país y según el gobernador local el
estallido se produjo por una chispa
generada por una de las herramientas de
los trabajadores mientras había una
acumulación de gases en el socavón unas
nueve personas han sido rescatadas con
vida en este momento están todos los
organismos
están articulados para mirar como
logramos llegar a esos cuerpos a través
de la agencia nacional minera que está
dirigiendo estos procesos de rescate con
nuestro corredores y articulados con
todos los entes de el orden nacional y
departamental para salir de esa
emergencia en Potosí Bolivia cientos de
personas exigieron la ejecución de obras
públicas y la aprobación de un proyecto
de ley que busca garantizar que parte de
los beneficios de la explotación de
litio en la zona sean reinvertidos en
esa misma región Ramiro cué Barberena
nos cuenta más
la ciudad boliviana de Potosí vivió
cortes de carreteras y manifestaciones
en la planta de litio de lippi
impulsados por el com zipo el comité
cívico potosinista cientos de personas
interrumpieron siete vías de acceso
exigiendo obras en la región y la
aprobación del proyecto de ley de
recursos evaporíticos el cual obliga a
que una parte de los beneficios de la
explotación de litio se ha utilizado
para el desarrollo de Potosí
Lamentablemente
tratado de generar un tipo de división
Pero aquí están las organizaciones
estructuradas orgánicamente qué queremos
el desarrollo de nuestro departamento de
Potosí qué queremos el desarrollo de
nuestra región porque como región hemos
ha dado nuestros recursos y lo vamos a
seguir dando nuestro litio el concipo
incluso amenazó con impulsar un paro
total en la ciudad desde la
administración de Luis Arce acusan una
campaña de desinformación por parte de
la oposición para tumbar el ambicioso
proyecto de explotación de litio que
impulsa su gobierno el gobernador de
Potosí buscó llevar tranquilidad y
prometió diálogo con los manifestantes a
la población de uyuni que estén
tranquilos nosotros
en condición de autoridades tanto
municipales como del departamento de
Potosí vamos a reitero redoblar nuestros
esfuerzos para que estos compañeros se
sienten vamos a agotar hasta el último
para que esta movilización pueda ser
levantada para que no podamos
perjudicarnos entre nosotros en enero
pasado el gobierno boliviano concretó un
contrato con empresas chinas para la
extracción de los salares de uyuni y
koipasa donde calculan que existen 21
millones de toneladas de litio lo que
convierte a Potosí en una de las
reservas más grandes del mundo y
cerramos en Venezuela decenas de
trabajadores llegaron hasta la sede del
Ministerio del trabajo en Caracas para
exigir Un aumento salarial luego de que
sus ingresos se depreciaran
drásticamente en medio de la acelerada
inflación en el país caribeño la canasta
básica alimentaria ronda los 480 dólares
según asociaciones civiles Mientras que
el salario mínimo mensual se ubica en
unos 5 dólares en un acto simbólico los
manifestantes lanzaron al aire billetes
sacados de circulación y realizaron un
sepelio utilizando una lápida en la que
se leía la frase salario mínimo estas
movilizaciones Fueron respondidas por
seguidores de Nicolás maduro
hasta aquí este Informativo en France 24
Gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]